-It is time to take a look at
the stories making
headlines today and weigh
the good with the bad.
It's time for "Pros and Cons."
Here we go.
-♪ Pros and cons and pros
and cons and pros ♪
-Tonight,
we'll be taking a look at
the pros and cons
of Mother's day.
It is this Sunday.
It's the day to celebrate mom.
But it can be
a little stressful,
so let's take a look at the
pros and cons of Mother's Day.
Here we go. Pro...
Con...
Pro...
"The password is 'password.'"
Con...
Yeah.
"You get the idea, right?
Yeah, yeah,
we care about you, too."
Pro...
Con...
"Golf in the...
You know,
Jack Golf in the Galapagos."
Pro...
Con...
Hey, that's what
I'm talking about.
-Oh!
-Hey, watch it. That's right.
-Topical.
-Pro...
[ Audience "Awws" ]
Con...
"Just sayin'."
Pro...
Con...
There you go.
That was the "Pros and Cons."
What?!